if you haven't heard of it before
l-u-c-e-n-a just a bit of a google or
check it out on chessable that's the
best way to learn
and uh that's when you only have one
extra pawn with black or with either
side and your king is stuck in front of
your extra pawn it's how it's basically
the technique how to get your king out
of the way in order to make a new queen
and there's one only one technique you
need to know to win the game and it'll
come in useful all the time
and okay we won't see that yet
but we will in a moment okay we might
see it we're going to see it now
we're actually going to see resignation
from duda he knows that once the king's
side steps the black king will help his
extra pawn promote and magnus is through
to the semi-finals yeah it's all over
and after three games today as well
magnus carlsen with a dominant
performance is ready for the semi-finals
to face lavon aronian no celebration
from the world champion but he must be
very happy in sight
yep especially because he struggled
historically in these second days
especially because it is one one player
that we called his nemesis